a pandemic is defined as an infectious
disease that spreads across a large
region such as an entire country or
multiple continents affecting a
substantial number of people a common
characteristic of pandemics is they tend
to have an initially aggressive spike in
fatalities and then either drop off to
safe levels or outright vanish fairly
quickly just look at any list of
historical pandemics and you will see
this trend however for cholera this
doesn't occur cholera has maintained one
of the longest running pandemics in
history spanning over 140 years five
continents and seven pandemics in this
video I'll look into why this disease
has ravaged Humanity for so long this is
the dark science of Cholera
foreign
[Music]
cholera is an intestinal disease
characterized by intense diarrhea
vomiting fever and cramps it's caused by
ingestion of the gram-negative bacteria
vibrio cholerae V cholerae is mainly
transferred through drinking
contaminated water followed by eating
contaminated food specifically shellfish
such as oysters cholera colonizes in the
small intestine of humans and is then
released into the environment through
fecal transmission into food and water
in areas where there is high population
density paired with poor sanitation
sewage mixes into natural or Municipal
Water Supplies causing consumption of
the bacteria the method of how V
cholerae infects its host is nothing
short of impressive most of the bacteria
you consume are destroyed by
hydrochloric acid in your stomach as the
stomach acts as a vat of acid to defend
against ingested pathogens however V
cholerae is able to survive this due to
several strategies when the cholerae is
discharged in fecal matter it's an
extremely large numbers often in the
bill the sheer number of bacteria is
used as a strategy for survival
V cholerate in larger numbers forms a
protective structure called a biofilm a
sticky mass of bacteria that form a
thick protective multi-layer structure
the most common example of a biofilm is
plaque on your teeth plaque is a cluster
of millions of bacteria that release
sticky proteins and sugars that cause
them to bind together creating a
physical barrier from external threats
such as proteins acids bases and even
heat biofilms require an extremely large
number of bacteria to be formed for
example about one milligram of dental
plaque contains roughly 100 million
microbes this protective biofilm is one
of the ways V cholerae is able to
withstand the acidic conditions of the
stomach stomach acids do destroy part of
the biofilm but it's so thick that
bacteria on the inner layers survive the
cholerae also survives the acidic
environment by increasing the pH of the
stomach or making it less acidic it uses
an enzyme called lysine decarboxylase to
convert the amino acid acid lysine into
cadaverin cadaverin is then exported out
of the cell into the stomach where it
neutralizes acids making the environment
less acidic the surviving V cholerae are
passed from the stomach into the small
intestine they use whip-like extensions
called flagella to embed themselves into
the thick mucus of these small intestine
walls and begin to colonize once
colonized V cholerae releases a toxic
protein called cholerotoxin and is the
agent that causes intense diarrhea the
toxin binds to receptors on the surface
of intestinal walls and the cells then
engulf a toxin once inside the cell the
cholerotoxin catalyzes a signaling
protein called the g-protein locking it
into an active state in its active State
the g-protein continually signals a
biochemical reaction which produces the
enzyme protein kinase or PKA PKA signals
intestinal cells to release a large
amount of sodium in chloride ions out of
the cell and into the intestine the high
concentration of ions in the intestines
draws in large volumes of water through
osmosis resulting in what's called
purgative diarrhea as much as six liters
of water can be excreted per day from
this aggressive inflow of water the
amount of water lost becomes a serious
problem when you realize that the
required daily intake of water is about
3.7 liters a person with cholera loses
almost double the amount of water that's
required for a single day in fact so
much water is excreted during a cholera
infection that patients are placed in
special beds called cholera cots these
cots have a hole cut in the middle to
allow the patient to excrete while
laying down due to the frequency of
excretion and fatigue that comes with
cholera it's more advantageous for the
patient to actually lay down instead of
making trips to the bathroom
additionally the diarrhea takes on a
milky white color called rice water
diarrhea due to the sloughing off of
mucus and tissue from the intestines
substantial loss of water from purgative
diarrhea results in severe dehydration
and can become fatal in just a few hours
though cholera infection has severe
effects the treatment is a simple
replacement of fluids and new nutrients
and if needed antibiotics however the
medical science of the 19th and early
20th centuries were not aware of this in
patients often succumbed to horrific
dehydration
and now a quick word from our sponsor if
cholera piqued your interest in
pandemics or you want to learn more
about a certain disease your best bet is
to dive into books written on the topic
but finding the time can be difficult
which is why blinkist is a great
resource for quick informative reading
blinkus condenses 5 500 books and
podcasts across a ton of different
categories into around 15-minute
explainers you can listen to blinkus
insights about books while driving to
work running errands or exercising one
book that caught my attention was the
deadliest enemy it's a look into how
infectious diseases like Ebola SARS and
zika emerged as small local diseases and
then evolved into pandemics through
blinka's condensed formatting the read
was only 31 minutes blinkus curates
Collections and guides that you can use
to improve critical thinking and
creativity with blinkist you can
discover New Perspectives broaden your
horizons and have well-rounded exciting
conversations also blinkist is now
offering blinkus spaces with this
feature you can create a space with
friends or family to add share and
recommend titles from the blinkist
library a space can be a resourceful hub
for book clubs hobbyists or discussion
groups members of a shared space can
access all titles in the space with or
without a blinkist premium subscription
if you want to create a strong new habit
or learn more material at a faster Pace
check out the link in the description to
start your 7-Day free trial and receive
25 off an annual membership try blinkus
today
why was cholera present from the 19th to
20th centuries unlike the black plague
and influenza which had short aggressive
lifespans cholera pandemics persisted
for 106 years from 1817 to 1923 there
were six nearly back-to-back pandemics
costing 7 million lives pandemics like
the black plague and influenza were
communicable diseases sickness was
passed from person to person when the
sick were isolated from society or
population size decreased from movement
or fatalities there were less
opportunities to transfer the disease
however cholera being transferred by
water contamination was unaffected by
isolation or population change due to
lack of understanding transmission and
not sanitizing Water Supplies cholera
persisted as people were becoming
infected from the water source and not
each other it wasn't until the third
cholera pandemic of 1846 that a
discovery was made in cholera
transmission the third cholera pandemic
was the worst of the seven and had
England especially hard it was during
this pandemic that cholera pits sprang
up around the English Countryside for
Mass burials English Jon Snow was trying
to understand patterns of Cholera cases
across London his neighborhood of Soho a
suburb of London had an aggressive
cholera outbreak accosting 500 lives in
10 days snow linked cholera outbreaks
with a map of his Soho neighborhood and
found cases where most prevalent in and
around Broad Street which had a communal
water pump he interviewed residents and
found that people who drank from the
water pump became ill with cholera after
investigation it was discovered that the
water pump was being contaminated by a
nearby Cesspool cesspools were dumping
pits where residents would throw out
their sewage and waste this Cesspool in
particular was located just three feet
from the pump and was leaking into the
Well's groundwater on one account a
local woman attested to throwing water
into the Cesspool that was used to wash
her baby's diapers which also had
cholera after Snow's findings were
published in the magazine the local
government made the water pump
inoperable so as to prevent consumption
in 1896 German microbiologist Robert
cook successfully cultured the V
cholerate bacteria he chose from sources
such as Water Supplies cadavers and
infected cholera patients proving that
cholera was caused by a bacterial agent
after the discovery of V cholera and
improvements in Water Sanitation cholera
pandemic stopped for nearly 38 years
this was a major contrast compared to
the average time of 5.2 years between
the previous six pandemics there is
however an ongoing seventh cholera
pandemic that started in 1961. the World
Health Organization defined the current
cholera outbreak as endemic to Yemen
Africa and parts of Western Asia due to
poor sanitation management and access to
Medicine responses to this pandemic have
seen development of a cholera vaccine
and robust sanitation efforts
[Music]
sometimes science can be seen as
difficult foreign and even boring yet
there are times when science grabs our
attention and draws Us in yearning for
more answers often what draws us Center
topics that are dark Macabre or
terrifying it's with the intention of
this video that you two were drawn in
and sought to have your questions
answered thanks for watching Dark
science